people don't understand it and you know
that's the thing I want you to clip that
part because people don't get it I've
lived my truth
you got your prospective so look and I
make more stuff for myself
when I haven't found anybody they didn't
create the content for the fans because
you're using ego perfection and judgment
to limit your scale no I'm the reverse
the reason I'm a monster is I couldn't I
don't tell them to do anything because I
think volume over my subjective quality
there's a very specific reason it's very
interesting I'm a very you know that's
exactly what's probably gonna happen and
it's and it's to your point it's a very
smart observation a very specific reason
why I popped in a mmm continuing and
will continue to pop in a different way
is I value the volume over the
perfection because I know that there's
because even if you hire me and we come
in and do a seven point nine of your ten
it's a net-net game because I know how
to scale because if you and I'd like you
to when you come and visit my dad liquor
store ten minutes from your house that
big building I build wine library
there's 40,000 square foot double deck
wine store it was because I know how to
scale this insanity from zero to 150
million in seven years is scale ability
its and creators struggle with it
because and especially when it's your
own subject that's what blows them all
away this is me and I don't watch
anything yeah right I don't want to soon
he walks away now the one thing I have
creative control over is my Instagram
right now where I will write the copy I
write all the copy and I will not post
things they send me because I'm not
feeling it and at our best and we're
still not there yet
I want to title to the Mimi stuff at the
top because I'm good a copy it's how I
am good
every single like when I diem back when
I heart a comment that a hundred percent
if it's Gary Vee it's that's why I
created the team Gary be account you
guys could create a family account and
have her run it you see what I mean but
Gary that's me that's why I created team
Gary Vee that's why I build up the rock
and all the other people for scale I'm
not scared to lose them I want to put
them on I'm all karma I'm all good I'm
gonna give you every best piece of
advice what I'm telling you and you'll
appreciate this I'm glad the way this
conversations going because I would
assume in a family dynamic just promise
me one thing that you're making your
decisions for yourself first and with
and then for her second and then
everything will play then that's fine
can I can I tell you something that I
really believe people who put their
family first at the expense of their
happiness always in a long-term lose
then you've putting your happiness
feresten I got it and for me I do the
same thing look at my Twitter bio family
first I believe the way I'm gonna bring
the most happiness to my kids is by
showing them what a happy life lived is
like like everybody's got their own way
yeah so that's great so how do you fit
it all in whatever feels right on making
sure my kids and wife are happy and I'm
happy to the best of my ability and
never over judging myself in a one day
one week one month or even one year
period cuz life is long and I'm not
trying to check a box for the camera or
for my parents or for anybody else and
that's where I see a lot of families
losing people are posturing for
everybody else yeah they're worried
about you know what judge when I get
from my work life bounce plenty yeah
plenty and I'm like listen and you know
I'm a funny guy I'm like you know you've
got a sense of me because you can see
like it's not like I'm like [ __ ] you
it's like you know I really understand
why you think that but you don't know me
yeah yeah you don't know what's going on
my bedroom like you know many people
come home at 6 o'clock and check the box
but are like alcoholics in a man cave or
like don't give a [ __ ] or not like so
that's how I balance it yeah out of
peace of mind that my intent is pure as
hell and that life is long yeah actually
think the sooner they can accept
judgment and know how to
with it right the better yeah actually
the better right like if you teach them
like self respect and empathy and
kindness and like if they learn how to
do it like better cuz that's who I am
all I'm like D's and F's
I don't that's my prized possession by
the way I don't know where it is right
now my report card that's my you know
why there we go you know why you want to
see a report card from you want to see a
New Jersey report card this is my prized
possession I'll tell you why because it
allowed me to get it allowed me to get
judged I was a loser by this this is my
high school for years these apps these
apps I was taught adversity from the get
right I think it's the advantage I look
at minority females I'm like if the
world actually understands what's really
going on with the internet I actually
think it's going the other way now I
think the whole world slipping like I
really believe that like like goosebumps
believe right look who's a goosebumps I
believe it because I think adversity is
the foundation of success and I figured
you were probably two thousand video I
didn't like it you commented back to me
it was a negative comment toward you
like you allow or something and I never
forgotten how sincere I thought that was
that you commented back to me and you
were nicer but you you just said maybe
it's not view or something and I felt
really ashamed because I'm like I was
kind of mean I never forgot that it was
2008 brother and think about and think
about how you don't know what that just
meant for me doing the right thing is
always the right thing every word I just
mean every word that just came out of my
mouth is based on the same [ __ ] I can't
wait to run into you guys and like and
like tomorrow a bunch of times but in
seven years you're like that point zero
one was it yeah I know I'm right you
know crazy this to have the internal
happiness to be able to take a negative
comment but you can't imagine what that
meant for me because people don't
understand it and you know that's the
thing I want you to clip that part
because people don't get it I've lived
my truth you know yeah
really I used to want to dislike you so
much did you got the best of me because
that would mean to you and I was
probably a big cuz that was a comedian
again and people jumped in and they were
they were like so I was ashamed that I
said this to you and your response to me
was just like something so authentic and
years later I wanted to dislike you I
mean I totally get it I totally dad I
totally got him years ago I'm bored I'm
like man I totally dude I totally get it
and so many things are circumstances I
don't think I'm so great I think my
parents are so great and America so
great that's what made me so the reason
I've rubato and confidence but the
reason I have humility is it's why I'm
so passionate about you guys winning cuz
that's what you're gonna give a [ __ ]
about what's great about Gary that he
cares I care a lot you care a lot carry
on when you have so much love and you're
good you're like you're like literally
like if I was to man up like to draw it
I'd be like well Myra here's all these
hearts I don't need them run man diamond
right yeah yeah all right take care
you're welcome take care
[Music]